I know what the I'm doing I'm
allowed to be here is vomit on your
sweater already Little Caesar's hop
right stop rapping about vomit we're up
next oh boy it looks like you've been
slain by my number one guy with the high
anxious brain
[Music]
you came you came there's nothing young
white coaches love more than eight mile
NFC
let's still hang 30. you had four QBs
whoops now you've got none oh what an
offensive genius another Debo run got
Big Dreams and think you're getting
closer what's that dpoi Nick Bosa
so Toby Keith was performing I hate to
pay the man but he's just a nepo baby
hey Shanahan how many snubs you get from
Brady
all right players winners decided by
whoever gets the loudest how does that
make sense
Nikki siriani says Nikki sayonara 317 is
the final score run why Eagles Fly by
Niners bye
Billy wins oh no the stripes are here
run
[Music]
everybody else got Deuce to pay little
Zach got a gig because he met McVeigh
hamburger eats giant Place sheets you're
gonna get beat I got read receipts the
weak ass rides don't affect me could
have been friends for my enemy Joe Cool
in the pocket making you Peg got all the
homie packages